we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 David P yesterday I interviewed
Christopher key who for a long time has
said he drinks and injects urine to for
health and something about the coveted
vaccine the interview was completely off
the wall Insanity many of you I I don't
know that we've gotten this many emails
and comments and voicemails about any
interview for a very very long time here
is just one such voicemail I received
hey David I was just listening to your
most recent episode with Christopher key
oh my God that guy's a nut ball yeah I
think he drank too much of his own urine
and the urine's gone to his brain sir
and uh this dude's a Christian and man
he's an embarrassing example of one
because I'm a Christian and he just
makes us all look silly along with a
whole bunch of trumpers anyways thanks
for all you do this
all right I want to say one particular
thing about the Christopher key
interview a number of people wrote to me
and said David why did you have this guy
on why did you do this some people said
it wasn't worth my time others said it
was sort of mean because he's clearly
out of his mind or just incapable of
carrying on a conversation I want people
to understand
he demanded to be on because we talked
about him on the show and that seemed
fair and I'll remind you we have covered
covet disinformation for years and the
covet disinformation has come from
Michael Flynn it's come from Trump it's
come from Sherry Tenpenny and we've
covered the covet this information that
was being spread by Christopher key he
saw our coverage wrote to me and said
have me on so I can tell you why you're
wrong about all the stuff you're saying
it seems as though if I spoke about
someone
and they say I want to defend myself
that I should grant them that
possibility so we didn't go out looking
to interview Christopher key it's
obvious that you know the the wheel
might be spinning but the hamster's Dead
uh
or whatever other analogy or metaphor
you want to use but he has to be on and
I had spoken about him so that's why we
accommodated it okay please understand
that we have a fantastic bonus show for
you today
there is some really sad stuff going on
with Senator Dianne Feinstein which
we're going to discuss and it's not fun
but it's we need to talk about it
Florida has rejected some Holocaust
textbooks for being too woke a Florida
teacher says she's under investigation
for showing the class a Disney movie
that has a gay character in it all of
those stories will be on today's bonus
show you can sign up at joinpakman.com
and get instant access to the bonus show
oh the bonus show where you want to make
money right everybody else that makes
money to fund themselves is bad please
help us make money on the bonus show and
if you've been saying to yourself you
know maybe I'll get myself one of those
memberships someday
once the price is low enough Monday
Memorial Day we're doing a one day
membership special
it's going to be out of this world
be notified of that by getting on my
newsletter at davidpackman.com we'll see
everyone on the bonus show or otherwise
see you tomorrow